KAREN: Okay. Today's
our last class,
and so, in this
presentation, we hope
to discuss and pull together
a lot of different themes
that we've talked about over the
course of the semester, namely
centered around
discourses of power.
So we've kind of
teased apart the idea
that there are political,
economic, social,
and linguistic discourses
of power that impact the way
people live their lives and how
they identify, and hopefully
by learning about these
different discourses of power,
we can find the treasure trove
of understanding identity.
RACHEL: So in terms
of discourses of power,
in the political
sense, in our readings
about the different
issues in the Caribbean,
we discussed the general
topic was colonialization
as a discourse of power
and how colonialization,
in all of these countries,
established dominant discourses
for racial, social, linguistic,
and economic hierarchies
of power.
We-- and how these
hierarchies kind of dictated
the structure of the society,
so the governmental power
went to a small
group of elites that
were kind of reminiscent of the
way the colonies were set up.
And then even after colonial
power left these colonies,
these new nations
were still set up
in this structure
of colonial power
with the dominant
hierarchies remaining
unchanging-- race, social,
linguistic, and economic.
KAREN: So we've talked
a lot, this semester,
about the idea of Caribbean
exceptionalism and Haitian
exceptionalism, but last
weekend, you kind of also
touched on the idea that
this neo colonial power
political aspect
is something that's
pervasive the worldwide
in post-colonial states,
like Rachel said, in maintaining
colonial power hierarchies even
after independence.
Personally speaking, India
is an example of this.
People from upper castes and
like Hindi speaking populations
within India under
British colonial rule
tend to be given a lot of
power, and that is very much
how India is structured today.
Also within the diaspora,
even like non-political
in terms of legislation, a lot
of the South Asian diaspora
is centered around
Hindu-speaking upper caste
experiences.
So then there's also the idea of
economic discourses of power--
that political
power kind of also
confers economic power on a
small group of elite people.
This limits access to a lot of
resources and global capital
and further helps
in keeping people
in post-colonial
stratified societies.
In the Caribbean,
you can look at trade
and how and unequal
balance of trade kind
of support more
importing than exporting,
which is very damaging.
RACHEL: And so, globally,
these dominant discourses
of economic power have a
parallel throughout the world
in terms of the distribution
of economic capital
and the allocation of funding--
of global funding, and so,
specifically, certain countries
tend to have control
over valuable resources
even if they're not
necessarily located
within their own countries.
An example of that is US's
hand in oil in the Middle East
at some point in
history and currently--
and then the idea
of international aid
being focused on
certain countries
based on natural
disasters and such.
KAREN: I mean, also if we
look, like, two months ago,
there was a conference held in
California, the African Global
Economic and Development Summit.
That's meant to help bridge ties
between businesses in the US
and Africa and lead to
economic development,
but none of the delegates
from African countries
were able to even enter the US
to attend the summit because
of visa difficulties.
So we had, like,
discussions of Africa's
economic and
developmental future being
held, like professor
DeGraff was saying,
by no one who really had a
personal stake in Africa.
So these economic and
political discourses of power
also contribute to socially
stratified societies,
where social mobility
is challenged.
Education is usually seen as
a means for social mobility
and subverting the
stratification,
but in a lot of cases like
we have discussed previously,
education and access to
education is also stratified,
and it is very unequal.
We've talked about
linguistics and, like,
language being a barrier to
accessing education within
the Caribbean with French-based
education in Haiti--
and the work of MIT Haiti
to try and change this.
But education is also barred by
political and natural disaster
issues and the idea that this
inequal access to education
further cements stratification.
RACHEL: Globally,
there are parallels
of this stratification
throughout countries,
and so the idea of
cultural capital
and different
countries' cultures
being more valuable than
others has kind of created
this idea of, like, ultimate
cultures to aspire to.
And it's contributed to the idea
of cultural assimilation, which
is happening in such
a global-- like,
as our society becomes
more and more global,
and there's a lot of
migration, and there
are more correct cultures
and more incorrect cultures--
and the same with language.
And so, we've seen, like,
situations of this cultural
assimilation in the
US throughout history
and throughout the world
but specifically in the US,
thinking about boarding schools
for the Native American,
where they were forced to--
where they were punished
for speaking their native
languages or participating
in their native culture even
amongst themselves and not
in an educational setting--
and parallels in countries
like Haiti and Jamaica,
where they were not-- when they
went to school, at some point,
they were not allowed
to speak their creoles,
their native languages.
Personally, the thing
that comes to mind
in terms of cultural
assimilation
is in the small town where
I went to high school,
specifically at the
high school, there
were three acceptable
cultures or, like,
two well-defined cultures.
It's like being
a white American,
being a black American,
or being Hispanic.
And within Hispanic, they
specifically Mexican--
not really being either
Hispanic, Mexican, or white--
being a white Hispanic
and not Mexican,
it was kind of interesting to
resist cultural assimilation
of, like, choosing
one or the other,
especially when people
would tell me things, like,
speak English because
we're in the US--
to which I vigorously
responded in Spanish
much to their irritation.
But it's just like having
to choose between having
friends and losing my culture.
Often I chose just
to be with my family,
because I was more
important to me,
but that pressure was
definitely present.
KAREN: Definitely also
someone who is first-gen,
the idea of assimilation
is something that's
had an impact on my life.
And for me it's
really been really
interesting to
kind of tease apart
the differences and
attitudes toward assimilation
between my generation and
my parents' generation,
because my parents were the
ones that moved to the US.
And for them,
assimilation was something
that they didn't teach
me their languages,
and for people of
their generation
that-- we have family friends
that seek to assimilate kind
of by not only adopting Western
American styles of dress
and language but also by
forcibly distancing themselves
from their South Asian
roots even if they
are born and raised in India.
Like, there's a
family friend that
refuses to fly certain
airlines to certain places
in the world to not be seen as
part of that South Asian crowd
and things like that, versus,
like, people in my generation,
where it's become kind of
a reclamation of identity--
a kind of like what Rachel was
talking about-- kind of trying
to avoid assimilation
by adopting
different styles
of dress and sort
of reclaiming your heritage.
But it's also interesting
to compare assimilation
and attitudes towards--
like, assimilation towards
the melting pot in the US,
versus in the Caribbean,
people tend to call
the US a melting pot,
but there's definitely
still, like,
stratified social groups and
cultural groups within the US,
versus in--
and almost as if
you're trying to aspire
to one assimilated one American
norm, whatever that means,
even though we're
supposed to celebrate
our cultural diversity.
But the Caribbean, as the
Walcott reading pointed out so
beautifully, I
thought that there
is so many different points and
lingering memories of vestiges
of different cultures
within the Caribbean.
They all exist harmoniously
and create a new culture,
so the idea of, like, is
the US truly a melting pot,
or are there better examples
of that in the world?
And then we've been
hinting around it,
basically political, economic,
and social discourses of power
also confer into linguistic
discourses of power.
There is the quote from--
RACHEL: Oh, and it
was very wonderfully
captured in several of
the readings, the quote
from the bishop of Seville
to the queen of Spain
when Columbus requested
to go into the colonies,
he, like, handed her a
dictionary of Spanish
and was like, "language is the
perfect instrument of empire."
And I thought that was very
representative of how social,
political, and
economic kind of fed
into linguistic
discourses of power
as the, like, predominant
vehicle for it.
KAREN: And today
within the Caribbean,
as we've discussed,
this plays out
in education-- in the
language of education,
in the language of
politics, in the language
of the upper class, where the
native language of a very, very
small population is
given so much precedence
over the language-- the lingua
franca of these countries
and a language that is very
emblematic of these countries
itself.
It's a language that
is a melting pot.
Creole is a language
that is born
of so many different
languages coming together
just as Caribbean cultures born
of so many different peoples
coming together, and
it's a bit ironic.
There's a Lippi-Green
quote that says,
"to take away someone's
access to their mother
tongue is to also
take away access
to their best tool for
social change," essentially.
And a lot of the
readings hinted at this--
that reclaiming language through
music like what Coke was doing
in Jamaica through poetry--
like what Chamberlin
was suggesting
is a way of subverting
these economic and political
discourses of power.
RACHEL: And these discourses
of linguistic power are
paralleled globally, as have all
of that difficulty discources
of power we've
been talking about,
in two prevailing ideas
that are linked together--
the idea of prescriptivism
which feeds cultural capital--
that there is a correct way
of speaking every language.
And then there are
predominant correct languages
and incorrect languages
or better than worse,
and this has been a
largely larger form
of global control of language.
And it contributes to the idea
of linguistic genocide, which
has now been documented
very well that it's
rampant throughout the world
that languages are dying
at alarming rates, but it's due
to-- it's linked to this idea
that there is a
correct language,
and the speakers of these quote,
unquote "incorrect languages"
have abandoned for violent
and nonviolent reasons.
And so, like, this idea
has been very prevalent.
KAREN: So then
now talking about how
all of these predominant
discourses of power
impact the shaping and
formation of identity.
So there are a lot of
complex in defining identity
in a post-colonial world.
The Barack Obama has a
quote that "the worst
thing that colonialism did was
to cloud our view of the past,"
but also this view of the
past is kind of something
that a lot of countries
are struggling with when
defining today's
identity-- is what is
our relationship to the past?
Was it a relationship
to colonial powers--
to countries that the
people of today come from?
And how do we or
do we at all use
these influences to shape a
unique national identity today?
If we look at Jamaica,
their way of shaping
a unique Jamaican identity
was through their music
through what Coke was
doing and in sponsoring
these dancehall music--
the popularity of it, and
through the propagation
of Caribbean poetry, and
just the idea that language
can be used as a tool to
maintain a sense of identity.
RACHEL: And then
identity also has
kind of a dual nature
that goes along with this,
like, choosing whether or not we
are colonial, or not, or both.
Or a new thing is that
identity is both self-chosen
and imposed, and you can choose
how all of these discourses
of power influence how
you define yourself,
and so then like the
idea, as Walcott said--
KAREN: Yeah, so he
kind of hinted at the idea
that historically Caribbean
cultures have struggled,
or people have struggled
with the idea of buying
Caribbean cultures as
being a culture of people,
because they're so
hodgepodge and made up
of so many different
influences--
kind of hearkening back to
the idea of, like, purity
and authenticity.
RACHEL: And so, using
this idea of purity
as a way of deciding whether,
like, what you choose
or what's imposed on you
makes you pure or not,
and how you decide to
identify with that idea,
and whether or not it's
authentic to have chosen
or to be imposed,
and, like, what
remains in your
identity in terms
of the idea of authenticity
that Tiango and Achebe
discussed in a
paper that we read.